Transcriptor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
¿Se acuerdan dónde estaban
el 20 de julio de 1969?
Bueno, seguramente muchos como yo
ni siquiera hubieran nacido.
Pero todos los que vivieron ese momento
jamás olvidarán ese día.
Fue el día en que llegamos
por primera vez a la Luna.
Quizás la mayor proeza
tecnológica de la humanidad.
Pocos acontecimientos
generaron tanto asombro
y tanto sentido de unidad como ese hito.
Por eso en Argentina,
lo recordamos como el día del amigo.
Yo soy ingeniero aeroespacial
en la NASA y crecí en los años 80 y 90,
sintiendo un poco de envidia
si les soy honesta,
con los que tuvieron la dicha
de vivir esa experiencia.
Porque ya se habrán dado cuenta
que yo soy apasionada
de la exploración espacial.
Mis padres me contaron
sus recuerdos de ese día,
reunidos con mis tíos y abuelos
frente al televisor,
viendo a Neil Armstrong
salir del módulo lunar,
descender la escalera y tocar,
finalmente, en suelo extraterrestre.
Siempre me pareció una injusticia
que se me hubiera escapado ese tren
y que nunca podría vivir algo parecido.
A ellos les tocó vivirlo en primera
persona y a mí solamente ver los videos
y sobre todo en las películas de cine.
Pero ¿qué me dirían
si les cuento que estamos viviendo
una época igual de alucinante
que la de la carrera
espacial de los años 60?
Que a nuestro alrededor
se están gestando los hechos
en los que se van a basar
las superpelículas del futuro.
Aunque no lo crean,
estamos viviendo una época dorada
de la exploración espacial.
Y los acontecimientos que algún día
pondrán celosos a nuestros nietos,
están sucediendo a nuestro alrededor.
Por ejemplo, ¿ustedes saben
que en este momento
hay cuatro sondas sobre
la superficie del planeta rojo?
Con lo cual Marte es
el único planeta conocido
poblado 100 % por robots.
Mientras hablamos, esas cuatro naves
están haciendo descubrimientos
que nos van a permitir ver el próximo
gran salto y poner el primer hombre
y a la primera mujer
sobre la superficie de Marte.
Yo tuve la gran fortuna de ser parte de
uno de los equipos que diseñó y ejecutó
el aterrizaje de una de esas recientes
misiones a Marte, el Rover Perseverance
o como lo llamamos cariñosamente Percy.
Percy tiene el tamaño
de un Mini Cooper,
pesa más de 1000 kilos y lleva
todo tipo de cámaras e instrumentos
para explorar de manera
profunda ese mundo lejano.
Percy partió rumbo a Marte
en julio de 2020, en plena pandemia.
Y llegó a Marte en febrero de este año.
[2021]
Desde entonces ha estado
explorando el planeta rojo,
buscando signos de que
en algún momento hubo vida.
Pensarán, ¿vida en Marte?
¡Pero si es un páramo!
Y así es.
Pero los científicos nos dicen
que en algún momento
Marte fue un lugar mucho
más cálido, húmedo y acogedor.
Un lugar mucho más parecido
a nuestra Tierra.
Sabemos que allí hubo agua líquida
y esa agua formó ríos y lagos.
Un buen ejemplo es el cráter
donde aterrizó Perseverance.
Antiguamente ese cráter fue un lago,
y no solo eso, sino que encontramos
rastros del delta de un río
en un rincón del cráter.
En la imagen de la derecha
pueden ver una foto satelital
de ese antiguo delta marciano.
Fíjense en las similitudes
con la foto de la izquierda,
que es el delta del río Dviná en Rusia.
En la Tierra, siempre
que encontramos condiciones así,
encontramos organismos vivientes.
Y los científicos nos dicen
que si en algún momento
hubiera habido vida en Marte,
esos organismos estarían en un lugar
como el que está explorando Percy.
Y que en los depósitos que dejó ese río
perdido podrían haberse preservados
signos de esa antigua vida.
Imagínense por un segundo
lo que significaría contestar
esa pregunta tan fundamental
para la humanidad.
¿Hubo en algún momento vida en Marte?
Primero, el sentimiento
que genera contestar la pregunta.
Después, el aluvión
de preguntas que le sigue.
¿Cómo era esa vida?
¿Era parecida a la que
se desarrolló aquí en la Tierra?
Y si no, ¿en qué difiere?
¿Cómo y cuándo se desarrolló?
¿Por qué dejó de existir?
¿Y qué significa para la posibilidad
de encontrar vida en otros mundos?
Porque si la vida se hubiera desarrollado
de manera independiente,
tan cerca de nuestra Tierra,
eso sugeriría que el desarrollo de la vida
no sólo no es un fenómeno raro,
sino que es casi inevitable.
Las posibilidades serían
muy reales de que haya vida
en montones de
lugares del universo.
Por eso no nos conformamos
con tomar muestras en Marte.
Si encontramos indicios de vida,
vamos a querer tener
esos indicios a mano para poder
explorarlos con todas las herramientas
que tenemos a nuestra disposición
aquí en la Tierra.
Por eso Percy ha tomado
varias muestras del suelo marciano
y las ha guardado en tubos herméticos.
Ya estamos trabajando en la próxima serie
de misiones para recoger esas muestras
y traerlas aquí a la Tierra.
Con lo cual, por primera vez, el viaje
a Marte sería un viaje de ida y de vuelta.
Siguiendo por ese camino, me parece
que es casi inevitable preguntarse
qué quiere decir esto para el futuro
de la humanidad fuera de la Tierra.
Por eso Percy lleva varios instrumentos
que están preparando el camino
para la llegada de misiones tripuladas.
Por ejemplo, lleva
una estación meteorológica
y un experimento que se llama MOXIE,
que está demostrando cómo podemos separar
ese dióxido de carbono que es
tan abundante en la atmósfera de Marte
para generar oxígeno que podrían
respirar los futuros exploradores.
Y hablando de exploradores,
esta es una de las imágenes
más alucinantes que ha tomado Percy.
¿Saben qué es esto?
Esto es un helicóptero volando
a 5 metros sobre la superficie de Marte.
Porque una de las novedades de esta misión
es que por primera vez generamos
una nave capaz de volar
bajo su propia potencia en otro planeta.
Es un pequeño helicóptero
llamado Ingenuity.
Pero no sólo eso.
Estas son imágenes
de un robot, el Ingenuity,
tomado por otro robot el Perseverance,
y enviadas a la Tierra
por medio de un tercer robot,
que es el satélite de
reconocimiento marciano.
A mí eso me vuela la cabeza.
Si yo hubiera leído algo parecido
en una novela de
ciencia ficción hace 10 años,
me hubiese parecido un delirio.
Algunos por ahí están pensando muy lindo
esto de los robotitos sacándose fotos,
pero al fin y al cabo es un dron,
cualquiera puede volar un dron.
Pero imagínense el desafío
de diseñar una máquina
para que vuele en otro planeta,
que tiene una atmósfera
muy distinta a la nuestra,
que tiene un campo
gravitacional distinto al nuestro
y que tiene temperaturas bajísimas
y además no poder ensayar
cómo funciona hasta que llegues a Marte.
Porque mucho de todo esto es
irreproducible aquí en la Tierra.
A mí ese es un desafío
que me resuena muchísimo,
porque mi especialidad es aerodinámica
y yo fui parte del equipo encargado
del desarrollo del paracaídas,
que utilizamos para
el aterrizaje del Perseverance.
Dependiendo de la época del año,
Marte está entre 55 y
250 millones de km de la Tierra.
Entonces, para llegar a Marte,
una nave tiene que viajar
a una velocidad exorbitante.
En el momento en que se encontró
con la atmósfera marciana,
Percy viajaba a una velocidad
de 5,5 kilómetros por segundo.
Con lo cual, en el tiempo que a mi
me toma decir la palabra “velocidad”,
Percy había viajado 11 kilómetros.
Desde ese momento, teníamos 7 minutos
para desacelerar a una velocidad
que nos permitiera aterrizar
suavemente sobre la superficie,
y una parte clave de eso
era el paracaídas supersónico
de 21,5 metros
que se desplegaba
cuando estábamos yendo
a casi dos veces
la velocidad del sonido.
Estas son imágenes que tomó Percy
durante su proceso de aterrizaje.
Son imágenes reales y es la primera vez
que podemos ver este tipo de imágenes.
Aquí pueden ver
el despliegue del paracaídas
que se infla perfectamente en
la atmósfera alienígena en 0,6 segundos.
De este paracaídas, que pesa 80 kilos,
estaba suspendido Percy
que pesa más de 1000 [kg]
y que lleva todos los instrumentos
que llevamos más de
una década desarrollando.
Imagínese estar en mi lugar.
En el centro de control,
el día del aterrizaje,
sabiendo que pasaba todo esto
y viendo por primera vez el suelo
de Marte en primera persona,
así como lo ve Percy,
díganme si eso no es de película.
Todas esas cosas loquísimas
que les estoy contando,
está siendo
una misión en un planeta.
Hay muchas otras misiones
actuales y programadas
para el futuro cercano
que están buscando
otras metas fundamentales
para la exploración espacial.
Todas estas cosas loquísimas
que les cuento
está siendo
una misión en un planeta.
Hay muchas otras misiones actuales o
programadas para los próximos años,
que buscan metas igual de trascendentales
para la exploración espacial.
Estamos por dar el próximo gran salto
y los protagonistas de hitos
como la conclusión de la búsqueda
de la vida en otros mundos
o la llegada de la humanidad
a Marte, ya están entre nosotros.
Las próximas películas épicas basados en
eventos que ahora parecen ciencia ficción,
se están gestando a nuestro alrededor.
Les recomiendo que no se las pierdan,
que disfruten al máximo
cada descubrimiento,
porque algún día un joven
se pondrá igual de celoso que yo,
de saber que tuvieron
la fortuna de vivirlo.
Y si lo que les cuento les apasiona,
como me apasiona a mí
y quieren jugar un papel,
no tengan miedo
de animarse a esa parte,
porque estos acontecimientos
podrán ser de otro mundo,
pero los que lo llevamos
a cabo somos todos de este.
Yo no soy ni descendiente,
de Neil Armstrong ni mucho menos,
soy de Buenos Aires
y además soy mujer.
De chica, nunca me hubiera imaginado
llegar a donde estoy.
Así que si quieren ser parte
de la película, súmense al casting.